out of the vibrant chaos of Nigeria's
elections a new name is emerging in
African politics
Obi has gone from Longshot to
front-runner in just a few months
Sky News here in London to Rally support
he told Sky News he wants to save his
country everybody can see they say to
youths can see that something is wrong
and we're saying we want to change the
situation the country cannot continue on
this trajectory and leading to nowhere
what would you as president do for
relations with Britain and why should
British people care about an election in
Nigeria do you think because it's
important
have 200 million people
which if the economy came today is the
huge market for Britain it is critical
for them as Britain exits European Union
they need Commonwealth members
[Applause]
London Think Tank he draws a crowd seen
by his supporters as a break with the
past
I think he is the right person for the
right job at the right time okay and
this is the right time yeah and we need
this to go right he understands the
problem and he knows that the huge units
are the future of the country and he's
taking advantage of that but the
challenges in Africa's most populous
country are enormous rampant inflation
soaring unemployment and endemic
corruption
insurgencies and jihadist uprisings have
brought widespread violence observers
say the country desperately needs New
Direction
I'm afraid it's in quite a mess there's
a sense of paralysis almost in Nigeria I
do think that a fresh voice somebody
coming in with new ideas could make that
difference and that matters to the UK
all I want to do
is dance he is taking on Nigeria's big
established parties
campaign is gathering momentum hoping
that'll be enough to win control of
Africa's biggest democracy when it goes
to the polls next month Dominic wagorn
Sky News